josefa krisada era un hombre que hasta
el viernes muy pocos conocían en irán
pero sin embargo su asesinato a plena
luz del día no ha dejado de causar
sorpresa en el país de la manera como
sucedió esto si bien no era teherán si
es una de las ciudades más cercanas
donde la mayoría de capitalinos o un
gran número tiene sus segundas
residencias muchos de ellos integrantes
del régimen y esto llevó a plantearse a
hacerse preguntas sobre la capacidad del
régimen para defenderse él y sus isla y
realmente la importancia de sus
servicios de inteligencia que ellos
aseguran que son bastante fuertes eso
llevó a que las últimas horas empezaron
a desvelar algunos de la manera como fue
asesinado este científico y a pesar de
que testigos sobre el terreno decían que
habían asesinos personas que estuvieron
allí presentes ellos aseguran que no que
la metralleta que lo asesinó fue operada
desde larga distancia que estaba en un
nissan negro que luego explotó y
terminaría por asesinar a este
científico que iba en un coche blindado
con su mujer y también llevaba un equipo
de guardaespaldas pero
debajo del carro en su momento y así fue
asesinado esto también llevó al gran
comandante del consejo de seguridad
nacional al y campanilla a vincular no
solamente israel sino a las fuerzas
opositoras en el extranjero los
muyahidin jalq que son los principales
enemigos de irán